welcome to this video playing gala from
Spain okay the Dutch maybe I should have
tried the staunton i recently haven't
got hit by this staunton gambit with the
black pieces and was totally destroyed
okay this is a nice result it just it
was just a nice structure for white wow
you're not much into castling are you
what okay yeah that's funny he's also
not much into developing pieces
okay so how do we how do we punish this
night f-4s a move okay I probably should
prepare it I don't don't understand
what's going on here okay 96 is some
threatening now night h4 g6 still
possible ok so just going to improve a
bit more Quincy to I guess is 36 not
sure how to play this let's let's
complete complete development first
I Bishop c4 ducks I look sir looks a bit
stupid really I mean Queenie 794 so
comes into mind if I play green c2g 64
maybe takes a four-year five and and
eyewitness queen when it's not it's not
totally clear the should perform EF but
ok it's them the way to play here you
should i phone EF bishop see one is
playing playing for that ok so i will
take i can take on c1 first yeah that's
maybe maybe a good idea not sure it is
to take now Quincy five and maybe maybe
I should have done that taken taken
first check but ok that's a it's pretty
promising in any case where do you go
Queen age 6
hmm I would like to enter here Queenie 3
and d 5 it's also possible okay let's
let's start with this asking position is
very insecure still I probably could
have done something better threatening
Queen g7 and to take and f6
now I can't let legs falling apart iam
okay i can also take here check HERE
king d 6
okay okay i can still not to move move
its pieces very much Jake here King c7
if I have five and a five to take so
this is this is the most precise
actually I think check you can play c5
playing folder for the main on the
background check
Roxy for snipey five only only issue is
a check as usual the time i have many
parts though check time morning takes of
70 there should be some way to pick up
one of the rooks would be surprising if
there wasn't okay I haven't seen it yet
ok ok I just just take my pawns
check-check
before pranay five so we cannot take
five points is really a lot check very
often queen against two looks can be can
be tricky also pounds on that side of
the border
this is not blundering one look Jack
think it does but very very difficult to
not to not blunder look here check and
the next one black resigns yeah this is
opening that's just totally unplayable
retaking here after that black is
probably lost with good play white
should win now this is this is too much
is the total of total piece of cheese
this position with all all weaknesses
and you cannot even even castle and b5
is just I know and a-five never develop
and so on yeah white white just win cm
just a matter of good good realization
unite f 49 f eight rooks you wanna I hit
many computer moves the computer wants
to go 92 now and then kareena three it
gives white a plus for Scott with equal
material yeah maybe that's it's even
better I wanted this this brutal way
okay plus form as well but yeah the
address s expected afterwards I took
here but this is this is even stronger
check getting his King getting his King
under under fire immediately check yeah
this is this is much much stronger
something something like this with
Quincy three and a porn that's that's
totally deadly position
also those pieces don't play yeah but to
eject blackest black is also lost
basically yeah not much to look at I
mean if you play an opening like that
never develop a piece cannot castle and
basically this more weaknesses then and
then controlled squares you shouldn't
wonder why you're lost after move 15
okay thanks for watching